if you guys didn't already know we are
giving away eight old-school bonds to
random subscribers to enter the giveaway
all you have to do is comment on my last
video and subscribe to the channel to be
entered and when we hit 5000 subs I will
randomly pick the winners on vid good
luck to everyone and I hope you guys
enjoy this video alright what is going
on guys it is statistically challenged
here and I have 500 million Venturi
who might be wondering what are we gonna
be doing with this today well if you
already haven't seen the title we are
going to be challenging ourselves today
to see if we can flip every single Third
Age armor in the game starting with 500
mil cash now I was gonna flip every
single third each item in the game but
some of the items like the longsword the
axe and the pickaxe are barely traded
like once a week so it would take a
really long time maybe something in the
future but yeah for this video guys it's
gonna be every single piece of Third Age
armor I'm gonna be using a GE tracker to
guide me about which prices I should be
buying and selling the items just to
really get a glimpse of all of their day
James they're pretty much right here
pretty much sums up all the Third Age
items I'm gonna be flipping if you guys
want to check out this website for
yourselves their sponsor to the channel
so the link will be in the description
I'm gonna start myself with the third H
plate body here as you guys can see it's
bought and sold quite often so this
shouldn't be very hard to get my hands
on it's saying that this is gonna go for
around fifty seven point eight now get a
put it for fifty seven eight seven one K
and that is the first piece of Third Age
right there
this one's traded about the exact same
I'm guessing it's because people buy
them in the set but really nice margin
almost a mil if I can do this correctly
gonna put out at around sixty two point
five I might have to increase this price
because this is really really stretching
it here it's closer to sixty two point
eight but you never know and it actually
instantly just bought first piece has
been obtained since we've already
obtained the first piece guys I'm going
to instantly sell I think I can get them
for sixty two point three we're just
gonna have them in there but let's
continue buying the helmet and the
shield a more iconic one the third age
shield if you had this back in the date
you were an absolute beast gonna try
thirty three point four eight 1k last
but not least the third age helm we're
gonna be buying for around nineteen
point six here put that one in for
around nineteen point six one four I'm
just going to take out these third age
plate legs and group them with the rest
just so it looks a little nicer over
here yeah that's third age muley down
let's move on to third age range alright
let's start with the koi here one of
them just sold for 11 points
three I'll try to buy one for 11.3 and
so it's like level point four yeah this
item is really cheap so the margin might
be too great but the goal at the end of
the day is to flip it for profit and put
in for 11 - nine - I think this is as
low as I can go and actually get it so
in an instant sold we got 92 K back to
the Third Age muley items actually just
sold as well so what we're gonna do is
put those back in gonna go for a mid
nineteen point eight note here on the
helm pretty sure we can get that if
we're just patient enough and for the
body so yeah it's nice we already have
four items being sold back let's keep
working on the third age range set Wow
today someone bought a third age range
top for a 50 mil god dammit dude oh yeah
as you guys can see just eight minutes
ago twenty four point five mil one was
sold at so I think we can get twenty
four point six easy so I'm just gonna
put it in four I'm gonna put high twenty
four point four mil here you probably
get it for that no problem moving on to
the third age legs if you look at the
highs and lows here sometimes it's
bought just at around fifteen point two
and then sometimes it's sold that like
high fourteen what I'm gonna do is try
to make the most out of this and I'm
gonna snag it for a low fourteen point
eight million then we can sell for like
a fifteen point is a chunky margin item
that's so cheap at a three hundred and
forty K approximate profit margin that
is really really nice I'm gonna try to
buy them at seven point eight if I could
that would be great and then I'll sell
them at around and then I'll sell them
under at just eight mil hey guys look
how awesome that looks we've got a full
GE of third age yeah I'm just gonna
check back in like two hours
so yeah I'll cut the video when I get
back just logged it back into the game
we bought a third age range top here we
bought for twenty four point four seven
eight mil and if we look at the graph
here just an hour ago and three hours
ago from that they sold at above twenty
five mil so I'm gonna put it in for
about twenty five point two mil
hopefully that sells right there that'll
be a huge profit on that alright I just
logged in here and as you can see the
third age range shop sold at that price
we cleared in that is one item off the
list guys now we do have been open a lot
last and final third age that is the
image that cut margin on the major up
top 1.4 mil that is absolutely insane
I'm gonna put it in for fifty two point
eight five
no I think that is a good price if we
can actually manage to buy this this
might be a male flip just off this one
items right guys it's been 10 minutes I
logged in and what you know the Third
Age helm sold I actually just did the
price I'm the guy included in the bid
but I dropped it around 100k sold
through a 1972 4k and look at that Marge
to show you the idea of the margins for
getting guys that is like an 800 K Marge
looking back now that is almost 720 k
margin and on the helm we got about 100
K Marcia's there not too bad
two items down all right moving on guy
third age wrote bottom will be the next
one last one here sold the 22.2 65 which
seems to be very low compared to the
other ones over here does seem like
someone did dump them we're just gonna
keep it simple here and we're gonna put
it in for twenty two point the Remo
number only down to one item guys the
Third Age mage hat so far this is going
really well guys we've done some pretty
nice margins and I'm stand I'm very
excited to see how much we can make
after we flip all of them okay guys no
kidding I just came back to check and I
was about to log off this is like 30
minutes later someone must have just
dumped their Third Age mage set because
these bought at the exact same time like
this one sold first than this one
anyways let's pop these right back in
alright so for the rope top we're gonna
chuck it in 450 3.75 mill I'm pretty
sure we can actually get more than this
maybe even 54 for like at one point for
a 1.2 mil margin but I think this is a
fair amount I mean we literally bought
it for 900 K lower so a 900 T margin is
still very nice I think I'm just gonna
try to get a 150 K margin and go for
twenty two point four five mill any
higher than this I think it will take a
long time alright guys so I went to bed
and this is the next morning later can't
say I'm upset half of the stuff is green
which is really nice to see
we sold the Third Age play body and the
Third Age plate legs gonna show you the
margins on these I think in total with
both of those combined we made around
400 K and we bought the VAM braces and
he ranged legs I'm glad we got that out
of the way now we still need to sell the
rope top the khoi's by the shield
and Selby third age wrote however now we
have room for the last third a charmer
piece which is the third age mage hat
now this items actually flipped a lot so
I don't think this will be hard at all
looking at the GE tracker graph I could
probably up my hands on this for under
nine point five mil and then sell it for
around nine like 300k margin which is
very nice so that is exactly what we are
going to do just under nine point five
million gonna probably log back in in a
couple hours give or take an hour later
guys we come back the third age kite
shield bought third age range legs so
I'm actually very excited to see what
you tracker is telling me right now
because the third age kite shield that I
bought for 34 mil right here and sold
for around almost 30 4.9 got now it's
likelihood of it selling at that didn't
do thirty four point six five just about
guys if we can sell for this that is
gonna be pretty much 600 K just off the
third age kite shield now I made a small
adjustment to the third age robe I
actually increased the price for selling
it here and I also just dropped the BAM
braces by a hundred K oh yeah I think
that's all me to do for now
catch you guys when I'm back on in
probably a few hours alright coming back
we have we sold the third a trio bottoms
which I'm really happy about because
look at that margin guys we bought it
for twenty two point three sold it for
almost twenty two point nine straight up
six hundred k margin on that item alone
also finally sold the thirty-two rogue
top only a 150 k margin I kind of
screwed up with that item but at least I
made profit on it which I'm happy about
and last but not least the third age
vambrace is sold at around eight point
four mil four hundred and seventy HK
margin three more items guys I'm
probably gonna go ahead and adjust the
price to see what's going on here I also
just aborted the third each kite shield
I'm definitely asking for way too much
and it just instantly sold at thirty
four point three five we bought it at
thirty-four mil 60 K 300k profit just
like that now all we need to do is sell
the third age range coif and buy the
third age mage hat and then flip that
and we're done the challenge I will be
back
alright guys checking back 30 minutes
later here we have Third Age mage have
bought I actually up the price almost a
mil as you guys can see
turn about at 9.4 and that's never can
happen it actually did go up in the day
yeah we also got a 50k return on this so
it actually bought for 10.15 I think I
could have bought it for much less which
is really bad finally did manage to sell
the third age range coif all yes does
what I want to see the Third Age made
chatt sold now for just hundred ten
point three mil and we're gonna claim
this challenge is completed guys how
much did we make but after the one hour
guys we started from a clean even 500
mil and now we're at 2.8 75 mil so we'd
pretty much almost made a bond flipping
every single third age piece of armor
and as we do we're gonna give two random
free-to-play players 500k look just just
look at that armor man that is literally
me ten years ago on the game but I were
just gonna swiftly run away and find
somebody else here just gonna give him a
nice enjoy followed up by quick smiley
face you just said little words can run
away in logout and that is going to
conclude the video guys if you made it
this far
you are an absolute baller you should
sub to my channel to get notifications
for what my videos come out again if you
guys want to use GE tracker and beat the
GE flippin my referral link it's gonna
be in the description again be sure to
go to my last video and comment your
runescape username and subscribe to the
channel to be entered into the 5000
subscriber giveaway we were going to be
giving away eight bonds when we hit that
and of course lastly guys until next
time